I had this myth that I used to believe
if I read a book I would somehow have a
skill and I feel like when you read a
book you have a general idea of like the
vague outline of what the skill might be
right you learn so much more from your
first hundred sales calls than you will
from Reading every single book in the
library on sales that belief shifted
when I was in that six month terrible
period of my life where I was like
deciding whether to stay or go I read I
think like 10 or 15 self-help books and
I realized that my life hadn't changed I
wasn't really learning because it didn't
actually affect my behavior and if you
look at behavioral conditioning they say
the definition of learning is that you
put the same condition and you have a
different Behavior if someone does
something in a condition and then they
learn something and then you present the
same condition if their behavior changes
they have learned something which either
happens to reinforcement or punishment
that's it I was consuming all the stuff
and in the same condition which means
that I had learned nothing despite
consuming a lot of content once I
realized that I realized that behavior
in action was the thing that actually
got me to learn